come on Arthur this is our time I feel
glorious
[Music]
glor we all know anything can happen out
there sometimes we feel
lost we push and we
suffer we keep going that makes all the
difference hey what happened to you boy
you don't look so good meatball look
somebody likes my meatballs play PAW
Patrol we got a race to win just
remember Michael this race doesn't
Define you I raced for 19 years this is
my last chance to win 3 2 1 there's a
young boy living in the city all they do
was over the next 10 days these athletes
will cross 400 miles climbing biking and
kaying that dot is Daddy go daddy
do that's St I gave the
Meatballs 3 days and 200 miles ago lead
the stupid dog and let's go come on move
D talk what is it
boy oh oh God can't believe I almost
walked right off that Cliff extra
meatballs for you my
friend he's hurting what do you think he
went through before he met us whatever
it was it wasn't good how the hell did
he get all the way from here to there
while we were onun bikes and zip lines
and running and climbing he must have
wings we don't know about the boy you
know I'm back like I never left never
you want to try to embrace the buckets
of pain I need a bigger bucket team
broad rail has traveled over 200 miles
and they've found a companion Daddy has
a dog what have you done think you found
your new partner in suffering Michael
yeah he's the king I think we should
call him Arthur Arthur the
king how's he doing he's been through so
much this B needs a vit I don't want you
to hurt
anymore he's a
fighter just like you I feel glor a
famous dog looks even worse than the
rest of you maybe you all deserve each
other always underestimated AR my
buddy this isn't the route on the map
it's okay just follow Arthur lead the
way
King I've never seen anything like this
everybody knows about
it guess what I'm not a dog
[Music]
person